[Applaudissements]
merci merci à vous d'être là merci à
vous d'être si nombreux
merci de votre fidélité après huit mois
de débats politiques si intense
merci de votre mobilisation sans
faiblesse pour faire vivre nos idées nos
convictions nos valeurs notre passion de
la france
notre ferveur républicaine merci à toi
ma chère valérie je vais être favorisée
d'une confidence
personne n'a jamais dit dans la famille
que tu avais mauvais caractère tout le
monde a toujours dit que tu avais du
caractère je veux ici te saluer
particulièrement dans la région du
président
je veux saluer ton engagement sans
faille je veux saluer ton talent je veux
saluer ta force nous connaissons depuis
de nombreuses années nous avons eu
l'honneur de travailler et de servir aux
côtés du président chirac auxquels je
rends hommage profondément puissamment
avec les mots qui ont la puissance
puisque ce sont les mots du coeur nous
avons servi aussi ensemble à bercy sous
l'autorité du président nicolas sarkozy
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes chers valérie une fois de
plus rassemblé pour cette campagne
campagne législative qui ne répond à
aucune autre et pour laquelle l'action
collective est plus que jamais
nécessaire
merci à toi valérie merci de tout ce que
tu fais merci de tout ce que tu feras
permettez moi également
dans un message chaleureux qui
accompagne tous nos candidats tous nos
amis parlementaires tous mes collègues
parlementaires ne salue et quatre
personnes en particulier évidemment le
président du sénat gérard larcher est un
roc
mais ça ça n'a échappé à personne il est
un rock incontournable et qui est un
pôle de stabilité et de stabilité pour
nous tous je veux saluer notre
secrétaire général bernard accoyer sans
lequel naturellement rien ne serait
possible en termes d'organisation
militante aux côtés de nos candidats je
veux saluer tout particulièrement mon
ami mon frère de l'ex chiraquien
christian jacob remarquable président de
groupe à l'assemblée nationale un homme
droit un homme courageux un homme de
combat qui a porté les combats pendant
cinq ans à l'assemblée nationale mais
dans le respect républicain du travail
du gouvernement
un homme qui a porté la voix des députés
républicains
toujours à l'écouté lorsque l'essentiel
était en jeu un homme qui a incarné une
opposition responsable
un homme qui a entraîné les députés
républicains sur le vote lorsque l'état
d'urgence était en question
un homme qui avait donné sa parole au
président de la république de voter la
révision constitutionnelle sur la
déchéance de cette nationalité
et c'est d'ailleurs la gauche qu'il a
fait échouer un homme qui s'était engagé
dans le débat au début sur la loi m
comrie et sir le texte n'avait pas été
modifié nous l'aurions voter c'est dire
s'il a incarné dans cette période une
opposition républicaine responsable à l'
écoute attentive et toujours répondant
présent aux côtés de l'état lorsque
l'essentiel était en jeu
[Applaudissements]
je veux saluer je veux saluer eric
woerth et je vous demande de l'applaudir
[Applaudissements]
en voilà un autre courageux qui ne
faiblit jamais en voilà un autre qui a
traversé des tempêtes et qui a toujours
résisté
en voilà un qui parmi nous c'est
toujours intéressé au fond au lieu de
regarder les crimes des choses l écume
des jours et l'écumé des vagues au loin
à l'horizon
en voilà un qui s'est impliqué à nos
côtés des lendemains du soir du premier
tour de la présidentielle et nous sommes
parvenus à ses côtés tous ensemble je
crois à offrir un projet de large
rassemblement des français qui
corresponde à notre sensibilité à nos
objectifs à ce que nous voulons pour la
france je salue notre trésorier aussi
daniel fasquelle directeur administratif
et des acteurs politiques et je salue
toutes les hautes et grandes
personnalités ici rassemblés un clin
d'oeil pour xavier bertrand qui était là
juste à côté un clin d'oeil en guise
aussi de remerciement et de
reconnaissance il a mené lui un combat
dans le nord qui étaient difficiles il
n'a pas varié il est là à nos côtés aux
côtés nos candidats qu'ils en soient
remerciés
merci merci à nos nouveaux candidates et
candidats
il incarne parfaitement et de façon si
talentueuse cette génération qui se lève
qui demande un espoir et dont personne
n'a le monopole ni le privilège
ils portent cette volonté d'engagement
total au service de notre pays ils sont
le visage de la france une france
construite sur ses racines et fière de
son histoire une france qui veut
préparer son avenir sans renier son
passé
une france confiante en elle même et qui
se bat pour chasser les doutes
une france qui préférera toujours la
clarté à l'ambiguïté ils sont de droite
et du centre et ils en sont fiers
ils forte il porte les couleurs de la
majorité pour la france et il ne s'en
excuse pas une seconde
ils n'ont rien à voir avec les
caricature grotesque et dérisoire que
l'on veut nous imposer dans cette
unienne et misme illusoire et éphémère
ils sont ouverts et généreux
ils sont sensibles et attentif ils sont
patriotes est allé coupe du monde
il disait mme l'europe à condition
qu'elles soient justes et fortes
ils les aiment la liberté il aime la
responsabilité il aime l'autorité il
aime l'égalité aussi l'égalité en droits
la belle et grande promesse républicaine
mais il n'aime pas l'égalité réelle qui
nourrit l'égalitarisme qui rend tout le
monde vers le bas
ouvrons des trappes à pauvreté est
désespérant l'esprit d'entreprendre
ils n'en peuvent plus des matraquage
fiscal qui ne résout rien et les étouffe
ils veulent la baisse des impôts pour
que chacun puisse vivre dignement de son
travail et ensuite profiter de sa
retraite ce qui ne sera pas le cas avec
une augmentation spectaculaire est sans
précédent de la csg il n'aime pas non
plus il n'aime pas non plus l'égalité
réelle
nourrissant le communautarisme tournant
le dos à la statue intérieur de ce
qu'est la république car en effet le
communautarisme
voilà l'ennemi il aime la fraternité ils
savent eux ce que veut vraiment dire la
main tendue il aime la laïcité celle qui
fait que nous vivons dans un pays où
l'état se tient à égale distance des
religions un pays où jamais on ne
tolérera de placer les lois de la
religion au dessus des lois de la
république
ils sont
ils sont nos candidats ils portent nos
espoirs
ils sont les candidats de la majorité
pour la france ils ne sont pas seuls
vous êtes là nous sont là nous sommes là
et nous serons là à leurs côtés les 11
et 18 juin prochains pour les
accompagner à la victoire
[Musique]
alors alors mes chers amis la campagne
qui s'ouvre est évidemment très
particulière c'est une campagne éclair
mais les enjeux sont immenses
c'est au fond la mère des batailles dans
cette année de respiration démocratique
qui ne répond à aucune autre c'est elle
qui va fixer les grandes orientations du
pays pour les cinq années à venir
et c'est vous qui choisiraient le cap à
suivre
je voudrais que nous saisissions à bras
le corps avec optimisme et esprit de
conquête la chance que constitue les
bouleversements que nous observons et
que nous avons vécu ces derniers jours
je voudrais que nous reprenions le
flambeau du progrès de l'avenir que nous
sommes les seuls à pouvoir brandir d'une
main audacieuse et sans ambiguïté je
voudrais que nous donnions la france une
majorité de droite et du centre je
voudrais que nous donnions au pays un
gouvernement de droite et du centre au
fond je voudrais qu emmanuel macron et
la majorité qu'il faut à la france une
majorité sans ambiguïté
sans faux semblants une vraie majorité
et non une majorité de circonstance de
rencontre et d'ambitions personnelles
car au fond et personne de sérieux ne
peut le contester
la campagne présidentielle a été la
campagne de l'ambiguïté à tous les
étages et si j'osais je dirais même à
chaque marche l'élection présidentielle
nous a certes blessé mais nous sommes
toujours debout
nous sommes les républicains et les
républicains ne marche pas à genoux nous
sommes la droite et le chante et nous
n'avons pas à en rougir
nous avons nos combats qui nous lie à
jacques chirac à nicolas sarkozy alain
juppé à françois fillon qui porte à nos
couleurs malgré la tempête
nous avons des valeurs qui sont racines
dans les combats livrés pour la liberté
pour l'indépendance nationale pour
l'humanisme face aux tyrannies nous
avons un projet dont les priorités sont
commandés par la nécessité intérieure de
libérer notre économie et de restaurer
les piliers de la république nous avons
avec nous des millions d'électeurs dont
nous sommes les interprètes mais nous
sommes aussi les garants nous ne sommes
propriétaire de rien nous avons un
mandat qui nous vient du peuple et le
devoir de respecter les 7 millions de
françaises et français qui ont voté pour
nous au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
on ne chôme pas nous ne sommes pas des
pions ou des pièces sur un échiquier
bon je vois bien que certains voudraient
faire de ces législatives
un vaste plébiscite pour couronner le
nouveau pouvoir nous serions chômé de
courber l'échiné sommet d'applaudir le
nouveau maître des lieux chauds mais
d'appliquer un projet qui n'est pas le
nôtre
bref sommées de renoncer à être nous
mêmes
pendant qu'on y est annulons les
législatives pour effacer toutes les
différences célébrons la fin du débat
politique
comme si le fait de ne plus débattre sur
les choix essentiels pour l'avenir de
notre pays
où vais-je honnêtement résoudre toutes
les difficultés de la france
[Applaudissements]
imaginait imaginer mes chers amis que
dès le lendemain de la présidentielle
les républicains et rejoint en marche
imaginez qu'aujourd'hui la majorité des
républicains est subrepticement retourné
leur veste
alors certains rappellerait la
malicieuse formule d'edgar faure
ce n'est pas la girouette qui tourne
c'est le vent et celle de jordi tôt tel
un écho et au fond en guise de
conclusion
être dans le vent c'est avoir un destin
de feuille morte
[Applaudissements]
les françaises
les francs seraient nous regarderait
avec consternation et peut être plus
encore pire que cela il verrait dans ce
revirement le symbole d'un dangereux
calcul beaucoup d'entre eux en
conclurait que la seule alternative se
situe désormais aux extrêmes notre
démocratie ont certes et gretel
renforcer sûrement pas ce scénario j'en
suis désolé ce n'est pas le mien
ça n'est pas celui de nos candidats ça
n'est pas le vôtre ça n'est pas celui de
millions et de millions de français
aujourd'hui qui attendent l'alternance
france durable en profondeur et ce n'est
pas qu'une question de principe c'est
une question et tu l'as dit valérie
c'est une question d'authenticité
nous avons des gués des convictions nous
les gardons et nous les affiches on la
franchise m'apparaît bien plus porteuse
pour notre pays une addition de
reniements et puis une élection n'ouvre
pas la saison des transferts
la démocratie ça n'est pas un mercato
gouvernemental la démocratie c'est
toujours le fruit n'a choc positif entre
des idées des valeurs des projets et ce
choc vital il se fécondent lors de
l'élection présidentielle et c'est tout
le problème car ce ne fut pas le cas
cette fois ci le second tour à fausser
le débat
une large partie des français s'est
rassemblée contre le front national et
non pour emmanuel macron soyons clairs
et je le dis dans le même élan la
légitimité du président de la république
est incontestable il est le président de
la république il est le président de
tous les français
sa tâche est immense elle le sera
pendant cinq ans et nous souhaitons la
réussite de la franche sa victoire
le saurait être remise en cause mais les
raisons de sa victoire ne peuvent être
et ne doivent être oubliées
d'où l'importance de ces élections
législatives qui seront vraiment le
reflet des sensibilités des attentes que
traverse notre pays
prétendre quand je l'entends souvent que
cette victoire présidentielle est
extraordinaire qu'elle incarne une
recomposition tonitruante me laisse
parfois pantois
les français n'ont pas massivement voter
pour un homme ou un projet ils ont
sagement voté contre l'extrême droite
comme je lé fais à 20h au soir du
premier tour
et comme nous avons appelé à le faire
cette présidentielle rentrera dans
l'histoire pour cette raison oublier
cela
ça n'est pas être à la hauteur du
message adressé par les français au soir
du premier tour
une république fracturé comme jamais une
france divisée comme jamais ou 17
millions de personnes au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle 17 millions de
personnes sont exprimés par l'abstention
par le bulletin blanc le fait qu'il ne
se sentait pas représentés par ce second
tour
cette présidentielle entrera dans
l'histoire aussi par le débat de
l'entre-deux tours où le pen marine à
poulets elle a montré toutes ses limites
et celles de son projet funeste dont les
premières victimes seraient celles
d'ailleurs qu'elle prétend défendre
plus que jamais le vote front national
est une impasse la tentative de marche
de construire un seul bloc autour d'un
seul parti politique n'a aucun sens dans
une démocratie représentative moderne en
république on doit oser dicter aux
électeurs la vérité sur la composition
de la majorité qui doit gouverner les
français présentent bien les
contradictions portées par les candidats
dans marche et la part d'illusions de la
séquence que nous vivons derrière le
terme des candidats la société civile se
cachent souvent des anciens
collaborateurs du ministre des ministres
des membres du gouvernement de françois
hollande ou d'élus du psd aux
fonctionnaires qui sont encartés ou
proches du parti socialiste
je vous propose donc avec l'ensemble des
républicains et les membres de l'udps et
io ka je rends hommage pour leur
solidité et leur force et leur soutien
plein et entier à tous nos candidats
je vous propose donc de donner à la
france une majorité claire
de droite et du centre qui nous
permettra de gouverner au lendemain du
18 juin le président de la république a
montré la voie en nommant au
gouvernement trois nombres sortie de nos
rangs mais la présence de françois
bayrou et des hiérarques socialistes
montrent que la politique de ce
gouvernement provisoire penchera à
gauche
alors oui c'est vrai le plus chaud
moyens d'appliquer nos idées et de
mettre en oeuvre notre projet c'est de
donner une majorité de la droite et du
chante et je suis d'ailleurs certains
que le président de la république aura à
coeur d'appuyer le changement profond
que notre majorité lui proposera et
portera notre majorité sera attentive à
respecter les prérogatives du président
de la république
la règle de la constitution est claire
c'est au gouvernement qu'il revient de
déterminer et de conduire la politique
de la nation dans une co existence
institutionnelle qui a déjà fonctionné
et qui n'a pas posé de difficultés
majeures qui a donc ma crème marc
marquez la solidité notre loi
fondamentale dans un peuple est dans un
pays comme le nôtre et dans la période
que nous traversions nous ne proposons
pas aux français une confrontation mais
un apaisement
nous ne proposons pas aux français la
6ème république ni la liquidation de
l'héritage du général de gaulle nous
proposons aux français un mode de
gouvernement inédit celui qui réconcilie
les français ceux de mai et ce 2 juin
toute la nation autour de la majorité
pour la france
[Applaudissements]
un régime à un régime d' équilibre
institutionnel et d'efficacité d'action
le rapport politique
le rapport de forces politiques issues
du chvo tour n'est pas le visage réel de
la france le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle a montré lui combien le
pays a été fracturée par ces quatre
blocs politiques quasi équivalent des
millions de nos compatriotes ne se
sentent plus représentés et se tourne
vers les extrêmes au premier tour près
d'un français sur deux était prêt à
choisir entre le chaos et l'anarchie ne
pas entendre le message et les
souffrances des électeurs du premier
tour serait une faute
à nous de les convaincre que nous
portons des solutions car c'est cette
france du premier tour qui va s'exprimer
au choix du premier tour des élections
législatives et ne nous y trompons pas
l'objectif d'en marche et de faire
illusion le temps de la campagne
législative en semant la confusion il
voudrait nous faire croire que les
différences les oppositions les opinions
disparu comme par magie
nous n'allons pas nous laisser piéger le
mouvement en marche n'a pas recomposer
la gauche et la droite en marche s'est
substitué pour l'essentiel à l'ancien
parti socialiste en marche
c'est une sorte de pavillon de
complaisance qui recouvre toutes sortes
de marchandises
on y trouve du socialisme de contrebande
et les éternels revenant des aventures
bayrou la devanture a changé le fond de
commerce est resté le même mais les
éclairs eux les électeurs ne seront pas
dupes
le renouvellement mes chers amis ce
n'est pas cela le renouvellement il va
se faire dans la clarté nos convictions
dans la force de nos idées dans la
qualité nos candidats 60% de nos
candidats se présentent pour la première
fois à une élection
en marche en marche veut nous faire
croire que la droite et la gauche c'est
la même chose c'est une imposture
bien sûr qu'il y à une droite et une
gauche et ça dure d'ailleurs depuis 250
ans l'histoire de france ne s'écrit pas
depuis des jours
il y aura toujours à une droite qui
débattront il y aura toujours des gens
de droite qui se confronteront dans la
même famille il aura peut-être même des
gens de gauche et des jaunes droite et
peut-être même qu'à l'intérieur de cette
famille des gens deviendront de gauche
pour se construire en réaction aux
parents qui sont de droite ou peut-être
même la verse
mais c'est ça la république c'est ça la
démocratie c'est ça qui est fécond et
c'est ça qui est formidable et nous nous
respectons parce que nous sommes des
profonds républicain alors oui des
bâtons oui assumons nous respectons nous
respectons la république les
institutions mais acceptons que le cadre
de l'histoire est aussi protecteur pour
l'avenir de la stabilité de notre
démocratie
qu'y at il en effet de commun entre ceux
qui comme nous défendent de travail et
ceux qui s'arc boute sur le statu quo
archaïque des 35 heures qu'y at il de
commun entre ceux qui comme nous propose
après cinq années de matraquage fiscal
sans précédent de berry s'est enfin
fortement les impôts des français est en
marche
qui veut augmenter de plus de 20
milliards d'euros la csg pour tous les
français qu'y at il de commun entre ceux
qui comme nous proposons une écologie
pragmatique et constructive et ceux qui
veulent sortir du nucléaire
fermer fessenheim abandonner notre dame
des landes aux à dist pour satisfaire
les chapelles écologistes
qu'y at il de commun entre ceux qui
comme nous veulent défendre et préserver
nos territoires en proposant un
moratoire sur la fermeture des services
publics en milieu rural
est ce qu'ils ne veulent investir qu'en
métropole qu'il y at il de commun entre
ceux qui comme nous sachant qu'un
français sur deux vit dans une commune
de moins de 10000 habitants veulent
préserver les équilibres territoriaux et
ceux qui veulent privilégier les grandes
villes qui confisque les énergies à leur
détriment
qu'y at il de commun entre ceux qui
comme nous prône la tolérance zéro
contre la criminalité
et ceux qui comme en marche combattent
les plaines pencher automatique pour les
délinquants récidivistes
qu'y at il de commun entre ceux qui
comme nous voulons maîtriser les flux
migratoires et protéger nos frontières
et ceux qui comme on march veulent que
rien ne bouge face au chaos migratoire
ma chère natasha bouchard
qu'y at il de commun entre ceux qui
comme nous veulent réarmer l'état face
au terrorisme islamiste et au repli
communautaire et ceux qui veulent la
poursuite de la politique conduite
depuis cinq ans qu'y at il de commun
entre ceux qui comme nous veulent
défendre la laïcité comme le seul gage
du vivre ensemble et ceux qui veulent
céder au communautarisme qui à terme
divise or notre nation alors mes chers
amis bien sûr les républicains ce n'est
pas en marche et je refuse cette
stratégie de la confusion
ma conviction est que l'on ne rassemble
pas la france sur le flou en esquivant
les sujets les plus difficiles en étant
dans l'ambiguïté quand on fait de
l'ambiguïté une stratégie électorale
on se prépare à une politique ambiguë
lorsqu on esquive
on ne dit pas grand chose lorsqu'on ne
dit pas grand chose on se prépare à ne
rien faire en marche près par
l'alternance de la confusion
nous ne voulons pas d'une alternance de
la confusion
nous voulons une alternance qui change
vraiment le quotidien des français et
c'est bien l'enjeu de ces élections
législatives parce que la situation du
pays est grave
après cinq années de déclassement depuis
depuis 50 ans le chômage s'envole alors
que l'emploi et le pouvoir d'achat
doivent être la première des priorités
depuis 2012 ce sont plus de six cent
mille chômeurs de plus pour la seule
catégorie à
les chômeurs ne sont pas une statistique
ce sont autant de drames de douleurs de
souffrance humaine depuis cinq ans les
violences s'aggravent les nos forces de
l'ordre sont les victimes d'attaqués
inouïe
l'image que nous offrons à l'étranger et
celle d'un état impuissant et désemparé
nous devons être présents aux côtés de
nos forces de l'ordre qui garantissent
notre sécurité qui se met en danger
ils ont des familles mais ils ont servi
l'état ils savent qu'ils peuvent y
perdre la vie on ne défend pas assez
nous devons être là au rendez vous
d'autres sont au pied du mur de leur
irresponsabilité au cours des cinq
années passées nous serons rendez-vous
est présent à franchir le mur de notre
responsabilité pour soutenir les forces
de l'ordre garantir la sécurité et
protéger la liberté de tous les procès
[Applaudissements]
l'affaissement l'affaissement de détail
sans précédent depuis cinq ans des
territoires entiers sont abandonnés
laissant des millions de nos
compatriotes désemparé je pense
naturellement à notre ruralité oublié
sinon victimes des années hollande 36 %
de la population française vit dans des
communes de moins de 2500 habitants sont
des hommes des femmes qui ont grandi 22
23 millions d'habitants c'est
considérable c'est plus que le nombre de
suffrages recueillis par le président de
la république
ils payent des impôts plus souvent que
la moyenne ils ont droit aux mêmes
services publics ils ont droit aux mêmes
désengagement de leurs territoires ou d
enclavement
ils ont droit à la même ouverture au
développement des infrastructures ils
ont moins au droit ou même des débits
internet
ils ont droit à la même qualité
d'accompagnement de la société de la
collectivité et ils se sentent oubliés
ne vous étonnez pas de voir aujourd'hui
ces gens se projeter directement dans
les bras ouverts par le front national
avec tant de démagogie car ce n'est pas
eux qui rend plus à soutenir alors pour
eux nous allons créer une agence
nationale de renouvellement rural et
territoriales à 1 euro investi pour la
ville un euro pour la ruralité
nous imposerons un moratoire sur la
fermeture des services publics dans les
zones rurales
c'est l'engagement que nous prenons lors
de cette élection de ces débats souvent
d'ailleurs très violent le sentiment de
déclassement a saisi beaucoup de nos
compatriotes et des fractures graves de
la société française se sont manifestés
aux ambiguïtés dans marche et à
l'irresponsabilité du front national
nous opposons une alternance franche une
alternance forte une alternance crédible
nous avons un projet pour l'heure
redresser le pays notre ligne est claire
et nous allons nous engager de toutes
nos forces pour défendre le pouvoir
d'achat pour baisser massivement les
impôts pour relancer notre économie pour
réarmer l'état pour assurer la cohésion
sociale
oui les 577 candidats de la droite et du
centre sont et seront les candidats de
la feuille de paie donné une majorité en
marche c'est accepter exactement le
contraire
la hausse de la csg voulue par on march
touchera tous les français ce nouveau
projet de matraquage fiscal représente
300 euros par an pour une pension de
retraite ou un revenu mensuel de 1500
euros
il faut lire attentivement le programme
et les petites lignes du contrat la
hausse de la csg c'est maintenant la
baisse de la taxe d'habitation c'est
pour 2020 en marche veut exonérer la
taxe d'habitation
80 % des contribuables c'est déjà oublié
que près d'un français sur deux aussi ne
la paye pas je vous rappelle que sur les
36 millions de foyers fiscaux il y en a
17 qu'il paye pas et je rappelle dans le
même temps que 10% des français payent
70% des recettes de l'impôt sur le
revenu et pour les impôts locaux
c'est également la même chose en marche
vous concentrer encore et toujours sur
les mêmes personnes et les 20% restants
la fiscalité de la taxe d'habitation
derrière cette mesure d'apparence
aimable et généreuse se cache
l'augmentation de la taxe foncière se
cache la concentration de l'usf sur
l'immobilier et il faut le savoir le
concepteur du projet dans marche est
l'auteur de l'idée d'un loyer
obligatoire pour les propriétaires
si ça n'est pas une charge lourde contre
ceux qui possèdent et qui ont fait du
rêve de leur vie d'avoir un bien pour le
transmettre à leurs enfants
je ne sais pas ce que c'est j'ajoute sur
ce sujet que les élus locaux quelle que
soit d'ailleurs leur sensibilité
refuseront ce transfert de
l'impopularité fiscale imposée par en
marche
d'ailleurs cette suppression de la taxe
d'habitation cache autre chose
c'est à terme la remise en couches
profondes de la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales
c'est la suppression du contre-pouvoir
locale et si on va un peu plus loin dans
la lecture des propositions dans marche
la proposition de nationaliser le rsa
c'est la suppression du contre-pouvoir
départementale et d'ailleurs si on
poursuit l'effort et qu'on va encore un
peu plus loin dans la lecture du projet
la nationalisation de l'unedic
c'est la mise en cause d'une partie aux
contre-pouvoirs social entre pouvoir
local contre-pouvoir départementale
contre pouvoir social
je trouve que ça fait beaucoup de
remises en cause de contre-pouvoir en si
peu de temps
alors nous nous prenons des engagements
précis pas d'augmentation de la tva
pas d'augmentation de la csg une baisse
de 10% de l'impôt sur le revenu de tous
les français
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires et après 50 milliards
d'euros d'impôts supplémentaires depuis
nous voulons et nous allons rendre du
pouvoir d'achat aux ménages
dès cet été à la différence
[Applaudissements]
à la différence dans marche nous voulons
que ces baisses d'impôts soit financée
par des baisses durable de dépenses
publiques
nous ne voulons plus de jeu de bonneteau
on vous reprend avec la main gauche
qu'on vous a donné avec la main droite
nous voulons que les dépenses en baisse
sur le plan des dépenses publiques soit
supérieur aux baisses des impôts c'est
le fondement de notre sérieux budgétaire
mon cher gilles carez cédait ces baisses
de dépenses publiques assurant voter dès
cet été
nous nous allons faire un collectif
budgétaire en marche n'annonce aucune
loi de finances rectificative
alors que nous savons que le budget voté
par les socialistes étaient un sincère
qu'il y a des grenades dégoupillées nous
serons au delà des 4 % de déficit et
qu'on va même pas corriger cela après
deux à deux mois de mise en place de ne
pouvoir ça n'est pas le chance et ça
n'est pas la preuve de l'exercice de la
responsabilité au regard de la situation
budgétaire et financière de notre pays
au regard des discussions qui vont être
menées avec nos partenaires européens
oga regard de l'obligation d'arriver à
zéro déficit budgétaire structurel d'ici
la fin de la législature à lille
différence dans marche
nous voulons que ces baisses de dépenses
publiques choix voter dès cet été en
même temps que les baisses d'impôt c'est
cette condition qui permettra la france
à nouveau d'être respectés et de
redevenir crédible en europe
le pacte
le pacte de projets que nous proposons à
la fonction publique contribuera à
atteindre l'équilibré budgétaire c'est
incontestable mais les forces de
sécurité personnel soignant hospitalier
ce qu'on exclue de cet effort de
réduction et c'est normal nous voulons
moins de fonctionnaires mais mieux payés
c'est la seule façon responsable pour
mettre fin à la paupérisation
progressive de nos agents publics à
cette politique du gel du point d'indicé
qui ne peut être poursuivi dans la durée
je suis d'autant plus à l'aise pour le
dire que sous l'autorité du président
sarkozy j'ai été le ministre du budget
des comptes publics et de la fonction
publique en responsabilité qui a proposé
le gel du point d'indicé parce que nous
étions dans une période terrifiante sur
le plan budgétaire mais savait pas
vocation à durer
c'était une mesure d'un an deux ans
trois ans pour revenir à un niveau de
situation acceptable pas pour durer
réformer la fonction publique c'est
aussi restaurer l'équité entre le public
et le privé
nos concitoyens ne comprennent plus à
juste titre ce qui justifie de telles
différences de traitement qu'est ce qui
explique que la retraite d'un salarié
soit calculée en fonction des 25
dernières meilleures années là où celle
d'un fonctionnaire lait sur les six
derniers mois de sa carrière alors oui
oui nous allons aligner les régimes de
retraite
et oui nous allons mettre fin aux
régimes spéciaux et oui nous allons
porter progressivement l'âge de la
retraite à 65 ans parce que oui nous
sommes lucides responsable gaulliste
attachés à l'héritage des grands
fondateurs de la sécurité sociale
attachée au modèle de système de
retraite parti apparaît partition
attaché au fond à l'idée simple de la
solidarité entre les générations et
c'est parce que nous aurons réformé les
retraites que nous pourrons augmenter
les petites retraites de 300 euros et
les petites pensions de réversion de 10%
c'est la moindre des choses au regard du
travail qui a été effectué par ces
hommes et ces femmes
ils nous ont transmis le jeune et nos
jours apportez nous les respectons la
jette une dignité certaine dignité a
besoin d'avoir des moyens pour vivre au
quotidien
le choix dans marché tout autre c'est là
aussi encore une différence majeure
c'est le choix de l'inertie en marche ne
propose rien
source de passer un système à points à
la suédoise qui ne garantit plus à
l'avenir le niveau de pension tout
simplement parce que la valeur des
points peut évoluer en fonction des
circonstances
c'est donc trompé les électeurs nous
devrons mener également la bataille de
l'emploi en levant les freins à l
embauche
ce chantier il faut l'inscrire dans le
cadre de la réforme du marché du travail
que nous entendons mener là aussi dès le
mois de juillet nous ferons d'ailleurs
une session extraordinaire qui rame sur
le président du sénat du 1er juillet en
discussion naturellement avec la
représentation nationale jusqu'au 12
août
et puis nous reprendrons très vite après
le 25 août pour travailler fin août et
tout le mois de septembre afin que nous
soyons en ordre de marche
en quelque sorte est en ordre de
bataille pour discuter de la loi de
finances et de la loi de programmation
militaire
après la revue des objectifs et de
moyens nécessaires pour nous armer
[Applaudissements]
la réforme portera d'abord sur le temps
de travail les partenaires sociaux
auront 18 mois pour négocier au niveau
des entreprises ou des branches pour les
plus petites d'entre elles pour sortir
du carcan des 35 heures mais nous
fixions une règle tout travail
supplémentaire doit être rémunéré en
conséquence
c'est dans cet esprit que se fera la
réécriture du code de travail pour qu'il
fixe les droits fondamentaux pour qu'il
simplifie la vie des entrepreneurs pour
qu'il modernise le dialogue social dans
l'entreprise
en plus de rendre du pouvoir d'achat aux
français nous allons réarmer l'état la
france est en état d'urgence
à l'intérieur elle est en guerre à
l'extérieur baisser la garde n'aurait
évidemment aucun change et nous devons
faire un effort sans précédent pour
préserver la sécurité des français
à l'intérieur et défendre nos intérêts à
l'extérieur nos armées sont aujourd'hui
en difficulté et en situation d'embolie
financière gravissime pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république le chef d'état major des
armées
aux côtés du président de la république
a pris en décembre à témoin l'opinion
publique une première pour le
représentant de la grande muette en
expliquant que nous armés alors que nous
avons des hommes au feu c'est dire
l'importance du message qui nous a
adressé à touches n'avait pas les moyens
de mener à bien les missions qu'on leur
avait demandé
c'est donc notre devoir et notre
responsabilité là aussi d'être à la
hauteur des demandes et des exigences de
nos militaires de nos armées on ne peut
pas d'un côté leur demander de se
mobiliser d'aller au front et de risquer
leur vie pour la nation notre drapeau
notre république et de l'autre ne pas
leur donner les moyens d'assumer cette
mission
nos armées verront donc un effort de
défense porté à 2% de notre richesse
nationale à l'échelle du quinquennat
nous démarrons dans la discussion des la
loi de finances 2010 8 puisqu'il y aura
parallèlement la loi de programmation
militaire et la loi de finances pour
donner des gestes et que ce soit pas une
parole sans lendemain
sur le front intérieur
nous ferons voter un dispositif pour
lutter implacablement contre la récidive
françois bayrou désormais garde des
sceaux comme tous les membres du
gouvernement et comme tous les candidats
en marche et contre les peines plancher
nous voulons leur rétablissement
nous voulons le recrutement et le
redéploiement de dix mille policiers et
gendarmes
nous voulons renforcer les moyens de
notre justice et la construction de
seize mille places supplémentaires de
prison
c'est indispensable on a encore là aussi
et là encore hélas de manière
spectaculaire perdu cinq années sous
l'autorité du président sarkozy un grand
plan de construction de places de prison
avait été lancée il a été annulée dès la
mise en place de madame taubira au
ministère de la justice
départ doctrine qui par idéologie qui
part prêt à penser qu'ils par sentiment
d'emprunt qui part au fond une forme de
volonté de considérer que les
malfaiteurs sont des victimes d'une
société qui ne sait pas les écouter les
accompagner c'est ça la réalité de ce
qui s'est passé et nous avons perdu
encore cinq ans face à la délinquance et
face à l'inexécution de cent mille
peines de prison prononcées par an
comment pourrait-il être autrement que
de lancer un grand programme de
construction de places de prison en
marche propose de maintenir la
contrainte pénale de madame taubira qui
fait de la prison l'exception pour les
délits passibles d'une peine de moins de
cinq ans mettre fin à la politique de
désarmement pénal c'est aussi nous
renforcer face au terrorisme
les actions terroristes sont souvent et
bien souvent et trop souvent nourries
par les trafics de stupéfiants et
d'armes
revigoré par une impunité de fait tant
la chaîne pénale qui fonctionne depuis
cinq ans face au terrorisme je vous le
dis
nous serons d'une fermeté sans faille et
nous serons implacables nous dissoudre
ont tous les mouvements se réclamant du
salafisme ou de l'islamisme radical
je suis maire je suis maire depuis 22
ans
la france d'avant d'avant le 21e siècle
j'ai vu l'évolution à 3 comme partout
ailleurs
j'ai l'honneur aussi d'être le président
de l'association des maires de france
nous avons beaucoup discuté nous sommes
à parité avec la gauche nous savons
définir des consensus lorsque
l'essentiel est en jeu et laissé aux
vestiaires nos engagements militants
mais sur ce sujet nous convergeons
l'évolution le développement d'une
certaine manière les ramifications
partout en france quel que soit la
taille de la commune
quel que soit le département quelle que
soit la région convergent vers une
obligation de prendre des mesures d'une
fermeté sans faille contre ces
mouvements salafistes -des islamiste
radicale
nous devons le faire sur les locaux nous
devons le faire dans la surveillance
d'internet
nous devons le faire dans ce qui se dit
nous ne pouvons rien tolérer plus rien
tolérée au nom d'un d'islamisme radical
qui détruit la république qui insultent
les musulmans et qui fait qu'on a
aujourd'hui des interrogations sur notre
capacité à vivre ensemble nous allons
faire la même chose pour les
associations qui prônent la haine qui
prônent la violence ou ma chère valérie
qui prône les discriminations notamment
à l'encontre des femmes et nous
sanctionnerons plus fermement les
contrevenants récidiviste du port du
voile intégral
ce que nous avons fait à l'unanimité
d'ailleurs de la représentation
nationale était malheureusement
insuffisant oui il ya une noire mais
elle n'est pas appliquée oui il faut
renforcer la loi pour qu'il soit
appliqué et sans donner des moyens sur
le terrain pour faire en sorte que tout
le monde soit respectée à commencer par
la femme et le devons respecter la
dignité des femmes
c'est une question d'une certaine idée
du modèle républicain de la façon de
vivre dans une démocratie avancée et
d'une société avancée à l'échelle
européenne c'est le même débat
la convention européenne des droits de
l'homme a montré aussi ce chemin pour
une fois nous travaillerons avec nos
partenaires et nos amis pour aller de
concert et que ce soit un sujet de
reconquête européenne face au chaos
migratoires nous maintiendrons le
contrôle aux frontières tant que
schengen n'aura pas été réformé c'est
clair c'est net et précis très simple
tout le monde peut le comprendre
tout le monde peut l'entendre ce n'est
pas une mesure anti europe est une
mesure de protection c'est pas nous qui
l'avons fait c'est le gouvernement
socialiste bernard cazeneuve était
ministre de l'intérieur à l'époque c'est
une mesure de première nécessité
j'ajoute que ce rendez vous il vient
très vite puisque c'est à l'automne car
la fin du processus dérogatoire au droit
commun de l'autorisation de la fermeture
des frontières ou du rétablissement des
frontières dans le cadre du traité
européen de schengen trouvera ses
limites à la fin de l'automne
il faut donc ne pas perdre de temps et
engager ces discussions avec nos
partenaires
dès l'ouverture de la session
extraordinaire nous donnerons également
au parlement le pouvoir de voter des
quotas d'immigration pour la diviser par
deux ou cher brice et la franche a le
droit de décider comme tous les pays qui
l accueille en fonction de ses capacités
c'est une question de dignité humaine
c'est une question de respect des autres
et de soi même
nous ne sommes pas en situation de faire
un parcours digne et respectable
tout au long d'une tranche de vie pour
tant et tant de monde qui pense
malheureusement encore que la france est
en elle des ro un eldorado qu'elle n'est
plus depuis longtemps
notre projet remet également l'école au
coeur de notre ambition l'école c'est le
lieu de l'ascenseur social
je crois en l'école comme le creuset de
la république je crois en l'école comme
le creuset de la méritocratie
voilà ce que doit être notre objectif
nous allons créer des bourgs ch
permettant la prise en charge des frais
de scolarité pour les élèves méritants
je veux saluer le travail de la région
ile de france
je veux saluer le travail des hauts de
france je veux saluer le travail de la
région grand est qui travaillent ou si
là dessus je veux souligner l'importance
d'avoir fait basculer ces grandes
régions sur notre responsabilité car
nous sommes plus que tout autre et nous
le démontrons attentif à la prise en
charge des élèves méritants
une centaine de lauréats par académie
seront ainsi désigné chacun des et les
professeurs seront naturellement associé
au choix
dans le même esprit nous allons redonner
vie aux internats d'excellence mis en
place sous l'autorité du président de la
république du président sarkozy là aussi
nous avons été en phase avec l'évolution
de la société
un programme qui aura été supprimée sous
quinquennat précédent alors qu'il
permettait précisément aux plus
talentueux d'étudier dans de bonnes
conditions sans considération de fortune
nous allons également renforcer des
savoirs fondamentaux pour qu'aucun élève
n'entre au 6e sans savoir lire écrire
compter et connaissent l'histoire de
notre pays
[Applaudissements]
la réforme des rythmes scolaires a créé
la confusion entre le temps scolaire et
le temps périscolaire nous y mettrons
fin comme nous abrogerons la réforme du
collège le collège ne peut pas être le
lieu d'expérimentation pédagogistes
alors qu'année après année la france
dégringole dans les classements
internationaux
la jeunesse de notre pays mérite mieux
que cela
l'alternance enfin mes chers amis c'est
aussi remettre la famille au coeur de
notre projet nous la remettrons au coeur
de notre politique fiscale
là où en marche porte l'héritage de la
politique de françois hollande
nous allons réinstaurer l'universalité
des allocations familiales et nous
allons porter le quotient familial au
niveau qui était le sien avant 2012 mon
cher eric woerth et nous devons le dire
à toutes les femmes qui ne veulent plus
avoir à choisir entre travailler et
faire garder leurs enfants à toutes ces
familles qui se désespèrent du coût que
représente l'aide à domicile pour leurs
parents dépendants que là encore le
changement sera très concrets dès cet
été
il n'y aura plus aucune charge sur les
emplois à domicile c'est une baisse de
pour champ par rapport à ce que les
familles paient aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
à
alors mes chers amis nous sommes prêts
nous sommes prêts à engager le
redressement de la france
redressement dont notre pays a besoin
nous sommes près tout d'abord parce que
notre projet est solide
nous sommes prêts ensuite parce que nous
avons une équipe rassemblée et qui sera
soutenu à l'assemblée nationale par une
majorité cohérente et stable les 577
candidats de la droite et du centre que
nous avons investi en témoigne nous
sommes prêts et enfin parce que notre
calendrier est connu
les français savent que si lyndon une
majorité pour la france dès cet été
nous mènerons les réformes pour
lesquelles nous serons élus alors mes
chers amis je vous demande de mener ce
combat je vous le demande au nom de tous
les collègues qui m'ont demandé d'être à
leurs côtés sur le terrain pour ces
quatre semaines je le fais avec la foi
chevillée au corps je le fais avec
passion parce que c'est toujours un
honneur une chance de mener une campagne
c'est toujours un honneur et une chance
de rencontrer des gens je n'ai jamais
croisé une telle intensité dans un
regard que celui de la ferveur et des
partages de vivre ensemble des
convictions communes et de se battre
pour un projet commun au service des
autres je n'ai
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai jamais imaginé autre chose que
de pouvoir mener cette action pour
lequel on vous ment date sans aimer
profondément et puissamment les autres
que l'on sert avec passion et avec le
coeur ce combat c'est donc bien celui
des convictions contre l'ambiguïté ce
combat c'est celui qui refuse un chèque
en blanc et un face à face exclusif
entre en marche et le front national
mes chers amis c'est maintenant qu'il
faut se mobiliser
c'est maintenant qu'il faut poser c'est
maintenant qu'il faut choisir une
véritable alternance
rien n'est écrit je voulais sûr rien
n'est écrit
il y à une première surprise on pensait
qu'il fallait 25 à 30 ans à c'était mon
côté chiraquien forever pour faire un
président de la république en deux ans
un inconnu devient le chef de l'état
deuxième principe qui a volé en éclats
les partis de gouvernement le ps et la
formation gaulliste dans son évolution
la plus récente regroupant les libéraux
les démocrates chrétiens les radicaux
une série de personnalités puissantes
forte et qui aime tout autant leur pays
que nous tous réunis on pensait que le
ps et les gaullistes été gagé pour
l'éternité dans une logique de
succession et d'alternance ce ne fut pas
le cas
les deux partis de gouvernement ont
trébuché au pied du premier tour est la
troisième surprise je vous l'annonçais
matin midi et soir on vous dit il faut
une majorité proprio la république c'est
tellement évident c'est un nouveau monde
la france est une page blanche elle
s'écrie maintenant on vous parle
d'ailleurs de la france d'avant au moins
la france d'avancer avant jésus-christ
après jésus-christ c'est pas avant un
nouveau président et après un nouveau
président
[Musique]
on n'a pas une france d'avant une france
d'après ya des français qui vont se
battre et qui veulent choisir et lever
toutes les ambiguïtés et ya des français
qui ne veulent pas se retrouver dans un
parti unique et regardez le front
national pour suivre
d'année en année d'élections en
élections le désastre d'un populisme
d'un poujadisme et de flatter les bas
instincts qui se terminera
inexorablement par de la violence c'est
maintenant c'est maintenant mes chers
amis qu'il faut se mobiliser
rien n'est joué ne laissez personne
décider à votre place
nous devons aller au bout de notre
engagement c'est notre devoir c'est
notre responsabilité pour nos idées pour
nos valeurs pour nos convictions
pour la france c'est l'avenir de la
france qui est en jeu c'est cette france
que vous aimez plus que tout c'est dans
3 semaines que tout se joue les 11 et 18
juin prochains
donnant une majorité pour la france pour
que vive la république
et pour que vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
là
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
quand on
[Musique]
et
les commerçants
[Musique]
e
ap